all right those Late Night fireworks lit
up the sky and unfortunately also set
areas Ablaze Clark County fire
department is reporting nearly a hundred
and they're assuming fireworks are to
blame Florida joins us live in studio to
break down some of the numbers people's
reactions Lauren it's like we go over
this every single year they seem
surprised but unfortunately with the
wind and the heat it was kind of almost
doomed to happen yeah those weather
conditions out there were very strenuous
and yes nearly 100 fires over the course
of five hours and that tally could go up
while the department gets a final count
and confirms the cause the Clark County
Fire Department's preliminary numbers
show a majority were tree and brush
fires besides outside there were nine
building fires they're all out and under
investigation but Priceless items were
lost to the Flames last night we spoke
to a man picking up the pieces after a
garage fire in the East Valley destroyed
some family heirlooms
this is all the time every year almost
non-stop with the um Fireworks but I
think this is what did it it's starting
to sink in right now
now the estimated cost of the damage has
not been released yet firefighters say
this is a reminder that setting off
fireworks in Clark County is now illegal
if you are caught setting off illegal
fireworks you could face up to a one
thousand dollar fine and we'll be
monitoring the latest numbers of those
fires as they come in live in studio
Lauren negretti 8 news now yeah it's
tough to see a loss a lot of things for
folks Lauren thank you take a look at
this one this happened just before 12 30
in the morning fire department called to
a home at Southern Highlands Parkway
they say this two-story home fully in
golf 36 firefighters responded the good
news is no injuries to report they are
still looking into the cause of the fire
but certainly a tough morning for folks
there